صباح الخير كيك تعودين نقلكم هلا بدنا
نقول لكم مساء الخير واحنا مش بالعاصمه
الفرنسيه ابدا احنا في النورماندي وهون
هاي المنطقه هي غرب فرنسا بدنا نحكي عن
العادات الرمضانيه وكيف يختلف موعد
الافطار في رمضان المبارك من بلد الى اخر
يعني في اوروبا وهذا يعتمد اولا على فصل
تاريخ ووقوع شهر رمضان فصيفا يا نادين
وسهام يكون وقت الغروب في ساعات متاخره قد
تصل الى العاشره والنصف في فرنسا وبلدان
غرب اوروبا اما بالنسبه للبلدان
الاسكندنافيه وفنلندا فيتغير
التغيب الشمس لبضع ساعات وعندما زرت
ايسلندا اذكر تماما في شهر الصيف او او
رمضان داعشني اسلوب الصيام والافطار هناك
في العاصمه نظرا لعدم غروب الشمس الا
لساعات قليله وهذا يعتمد يعني هناك
المسلمون هذه البلد او الصيام والافطار
على توقيت منطقه البرتان اقصى غرب فرنسا
التي لا تبعد من هذه المنطقه الموجود فيها
انا اما شتاء في فصل الشتاء فالوضع مختلف
اذ تكون ساعات الصيام في بعض المناطق
الشماليه في القاره الاوروبيه وحتى خارج
اوروبا كمنطقه بيتاجونيا اقصى جنوب الكره
الارضيه بين الارجنتين وتشيلي لا تتجاوز
الساعتين يوميا بسبب غياب الشمس الطويل
هناك وفي افريقيا تحديدا يحث خطباء مساجد
الكوت ديفوار او ساحل العاج المسلمين او
المؤمنون على تقديم المساعدات المحتاجين
حتى وان كانوا من غير المسلمين وكمان في
افريقيا ونيجيريا هالبلد نجد فيه
المسحراتي ليس شخصا منفردا بل الفرق فرق
كامله تجوب الشوارع ويحمل افرادها الطبول
وساحل العاج كوت ديفوار يحثها طبعا حكينا
عن هذا الشيخ وانه كيف يحق ان مساعده
الاخرين وفي كتير اشياء بتختلف اذا رحنا
مثلا على اسيا الوسطى هذا بيجار البلد
زرناها باكو يتم تنظيف تنظيم في بدايه
رمضان سباقات الخيل ويتوارث اهل البلاد
عادت تحضير صحن اضافي على المائده مائده
الافطار في حاله الكره الارضيه موجود وحتى
يتناول
[موسيقى]
اغلب بلدان الكره الارضيه
عم بنادي الكاميرا لانه بدنا نعمل شغله
مشان نقدر ناخذكم بجوله ونشوف كيف هون
المنطقه كيف انه اول مره بتطلع الشمس
بترجع على هذه المنطقه وهي منطقه التي تقع
غرب الشمال غرب فرنسا والفرنسيا نشوفوا
كيف راسا هلا صارت تقريبا ساعات تقريبا
الهروب هلا الشمس
[موسيقى]
بالغيوم بس بنشوف كيف انه كيف اهل باريس
بهذا عيد الفصح هون بفرنسا اكيد الايستر
بنشوف كيف في كتير انتشار الفرنسيين الذين
ينتقلون الى هذه المنطقه حتى ولو لفتره
يومين او احيانا في يوم واحد حتى يتنزهوا
ويستمتعوا بسطوع الشمس في فرنسا بعد غياب
دام طويلا في هذا الفصل من هذه المشاهد
يعني هذا الممشى
الوقت للاسف وقت البرنامج
رح نقول لك من يوم وط مش بونجور شكرا
جزيلا لك من نورمانديك مراسل العربيه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات